foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
had some minor problems there but
welcome to uh Brandon turns into a let's
player yep
um though I'm gonna be playing for you
today yeah you're gonna be playing
Brandon and Charlie let's play Brandon
Brandon pontificates in Charlie Place
yep
um if you don't know this is the great
Charlie who is the director of moon
breaker and Creator and
Grand Puba yep onion worlds of yeah it's
you've co-founded unknown co-founded
yeah almost 20 years ago uh which made
subnautica yep uh among other awesome
games yep natural selection is that a
Sudoku anyone plays Sudoku in the house
probably not no one played that game
yeah we're trying to make money we
needed money so well you know money is
good money it's important it lets us
make more things yeah I mean that's
where Moon breaker came from like we
didn't do that we wouldn't have
moonbreakers so uh and I am Brandon
Sanderson you're on my channel I assume
you know who I am yep I was gonna
introduce you but that would be
ridiculous so and uh we together have
been collaborating on this video game
yes for like three years yeah something
like that yeah it's hard to believe
um I used to think that books had a long
development cycle right yeah like when I
first sold my very first book Elantra I
sold it in uh in May of 2003 and didn't
come out until like 2005 right around
that time I'm like whoa two whole years
little Did You Know video games yeah
video games and we are the worst because
we basically take five years to make a
game that's not uncommon right like you
can yeah some people can do it faster
but we can get faster I don't know but
you're the thing about uh about the
video games is it was that long until we
could even announce it right yeah like I
didn't announce a book pretty early on
but you got to get all your ducks in a
row we wanted this game to be good
enough that like you could put your name
on it you know yeah you just didn't want
to like here's a piece of junk and and
Brandon's attached to it and then ruin
your career that wouldn't be any good
um Love video games I mean I think
people have been burned that's why you
wait so long like people have been like
when you're gonna announce this thing
when you get announced this thing well
people announce video games yeah and
then don't deliver on them true and so
we announced and suddenly we're yeah
yeah which is two days a better thing
yeah yeah two days for Early Access yep
Early Access on Steam Thursday 3 P.M uh
PST uh games free to play so right well
so pay to download but we've kind of
built it so we can basically so we can
support it for years okay so we do have
some currencies and things like that
because we want to keep adding units to
this game okay so how much does it cost
it's 25 bucks 25 bucks okay yep and then
we have a Founders pack also which gets
you a whole bunch of extra stuff if you
really love the game you can spend an
extra 30 get a cool extra skin okay and
that's the Astro skin uh which is really
cool only available that way but uh yeah
30 bucks or 25 bucks is the basic okay
that's a game yeah awesome yeah should
we go into
um and do we this is a q a so I guess
yeah we'll we'll talk for a little while
collecting questions and things like
that so I haven't played this since it's
been a while it's been about I don't
know it's been a while since yeah like
this art was not here when I played it
um last so yeah hard at work on making
art uh if you didn't have an AI when I
last played it and we didn't even have
roster building yeah
so maybe I should show you that first
um well first of all this is a digital
Miniatures game in case you're just
tuning in
[Music]
basically one of the first or the first
digital Miniatures game so imagine
something like Hearthstone mixed with
something tactical like x-com or
obviously XCOM so you basically would
make a roster so I'll just show that
really quickly so you're going to choose
a captain and then 10 crew so we have
three captains so let me just choose
exterior he's kind of the good starter
captain
and then you can choose a whole bunch of
other units they all have you know
they're all a mix of melee and range
units and then they have like really
crazy abilities attached to them you've
been spending a lot of time coming up
with crazy ability oh yeah that's that I
like my dream that's the Charlie thing
that's what I love that's where you and
I connect yes I love the crazy magic
systems and you come up with crazy units
crazy abilities yep so that's exactly
right Furia this is her ability right
here
um so you know every bill every uh unit
in the game has a has a melee or range
attack usually they're you know just one
or two each Syria if you don't attack
with her she takes a damage and then her
attack grows from two to five uh and
then if she does it again it goes from
five to eight and then if she does it
again she goes eight to eleven until she
takes one giant attack and she's like
charging up her anger and she basically
lets loose
you can win the game with this one unit
right do it right you know that's how
that's how weird this game is like game
breaking
click on that lore oh yeah yeah I gotta
show you all this stuff yeah so I'm kind
of showing all you guys in the Stream
but also showing because he hasn't seen
it for a little while yeah uh what do
you want to see here I think you you
don't want to see Laura you have a lower
floor in here now yeah yeah uh so this
was
um okay Yep this is kind of like extra
lore so this isn't
um you know it's kind of all right so
this is for painting right well this is
just this is just kind of like a like
flavor text you'd see like you saw a
magic card yeah extra flavor text this
is just kind of bonus got it'll give you
a little more information about them
we have stats here which are not filled
in yet because it's early access we'll
be adding that um
yeah let's go let's let's see like I
should show you the painting yeah let's
see the painting you probably haven't
seen it I I did the painting for a while
yeah but
um so the question I think people are
asking is gonna ask are your plan are
your units just unpainted if you don't
paint them yeah they come with them
painted yeah so if you see here this is
all the units that Brandon has unlocked
even though I've given them a bunch of
extra he has the ability to unlock
everything but uh these are just the
ones he has now and you can see they all
are painted so like when you each unit
you get is yeah is painted but then you
can customize it
so if I do that I just do new schemes so
here's a defaults just blank yep and we
just went crazy we wanted to like make
this just like Warhammer basically so I
can just do like a paint a base coat
really quickly that's not a very good
color and do
maybe do like something like this this
is not going to be a pretty model I'm
just going to tell you right now
pretty paint job
so I can just do that
um you can see oops Mouse tends to be a
little too high uh they can do a wash
so let's see oh man that's so much
easier than a result it's a lot easier
than real yeah yeah than analog painting
I say real painting but this is real it
actually is real like this is this feels
real yeah yeah it's not um a lot of the
artists who make art for us work
digitally oh yeah yeah and they're real
artists they're real artists of course
yes yeah exactly but uh this is uh man
yeah let me show you how to brush now oh
yeah this is where it gets really cool
uh let's do like a white this is where
you get like this is gonna be a little
insane but get the idea so dry brush is
a thing where you take a brush and you
dry it out a bunch so that you can get
just the highlights
um on a mini uh my brother's uh big into
Minis and so I know a little bit of the
terminology I go over there occasionally
and paint and so we wanted to mimic all
that stuff
so yeah this is how you get that same
high level high level detail just really
quickly look at that I mean it's already
got some cool detail
we also have this really cool thing
people seem to freak out about which is
like you can paint just
a piece of the model so what's happening
here if I turn on this masking right
here I'm going to undo it it's Auto mask
this is normal oops let me see is that
on or off we gotta work on that okay
yeah so that's normal it just Paints the
whole model yep if I turn on mask it
will only paint the thing that I started
painting
so it knows where I put where I started
painting and it will only paint that so
if I go like this and I go all the way
over here it's painting all the fruit
because we cleverly basically marked all
the fruit together in the same group so
you don't have to like go through and
just like trace the detail too perfectly
this is a way you can get really quick
details yeah you know you can really
just be creative without having to so
instead of a fill function you have this
you got that's that's cool that's the
idea people seem to love it
and the painting you can just get lost
in this I mean super relaxing you know
put the UI away you just kind of like
Bliss out here and just get really into
like the little details now I don't
think it's in there yet are you ever
going to do the thing that I've kind of
been pushing you for which is uh better
than regular paints meaning like you do
yeah yeah okay we have them because like
show me some of those because I I've
been asking for for them forever so we
haven't unlocked them okay but I can
actually show you so they're all
earnable okay um oh so I just got lost
in there let's see let's go back here so
these are these are the cool the cool
paints they couldn't do it in uh in
analog paints yes so like metal glowing
pain yes because the glowing is the
thing
um like I've I would when you first
pitch this to me like years ago I'm like
so I can paint something so that it has
a a light coming off of it yeah and
it'll work like in the game you'll be
using your mini it'll have light coming
off of it yeah so I can't remember if we
actually have the glow paints on this
first season track okay but we do have
these metallic paints uh-huh and so the
these are actual like shiny metal uh-huh
this is like yeah I mean you actually
can do this in real Miniatures but like
probably looks a lot cooler here because
it can get like a mirrors but what you
can't do is like actual glue without any
like electricity or something like that
later we're gonna we're gonna add stuff
like that yeah we're kind of just
getting started the options for stuff
you can do with that are just incredible
right like what if you could paint with
lava yeah what if you could mean what if
you could make part of your midi
invisible yeah transparent or something
like that like totally uh the the things
you can do in a better than a better
than analog what did you call it you
called it better than yeah better than
Miniatures framed it yeah yeah it looks
like still Miniatures but we want to
like take it to the next level right
we're not trying to leave Miniatures
a little loud sorry everyone
oh okay
we're just testing because you're a
little quieter okay so bring it down
yeah like yeah yeah there you go got it
how's that
that's okay okay let us know everyone as
Charlie talks yeah a second we should
show the game yeah let's let's actually
play the game okay so let's play the
game for a little bit AI because Brandon
yes like playing players you're the one
who's playing I'm just watching that's
true and the game isn't out yet so
there's probably like no one online yet
yeah we gotta wait two days but
um so here is your roster right it's a
default roster we got still your your
favorite let's let's build him a new
crew oh you want it okay yeah let's
build let's build why not
rosters yeah roster
how many rosters unlimited unlimited
roster okay because that was something
that's changed that changed all the time
yeah yeah like
um yeah
so do you want to just pick some units
by like well let's see
um so talk about fear yeah let's get
hurt yeah
yeah our sweet new paint job
it doesn't look like much but it's okay
um what else so do we
um let's see uh London kind of unit
lots of lots of ranged units okay
um let's see what is exterior what is
exterior still melee and he's like does
he have the thing that spins around and
hits everyone next to him right yeah so
when I was uh last time I played I built
something that was basically he goes in
takes the aggro and then yeah we shoot
and throw bombs at people from from
right so uh but he's gonna need someone
to keep him alive yep so let's have a
stitchy in here let's get stitchy and if
we don't have him yet there he is good
so healer
and we do our basic plan is going to be
um run exterior and yep get him
surrounded yep helium yep throw bombs at
things and then have a fast unit they
can mop up
sounds great I think I pretty much did
that this Stitch you will be able to
heal him Yep this uh tournamenteo is
really good you can read the ability uh
yeah look at this thing
oh interesting like that's clever it's
really swingy yeah yeah yeah yeah so
that can make a tank yeah they have
basically have to kill your captain in
one turn uh pretty much not one of those
yep or yeah or just chase him down he's
really weak so he can be chased down
Brandon's exterior
kurzoo
done
okay all right let's see what we're
doing okay we're doing all right uh oops
wrong place here play now when I played
last time I got a randomized screw I
couldn't pick them yep
that's getting tweaked we listened to
even internal feedback we're just like I
mean that was my big thing I want I
won't belabor it too much but um
basically we wanted to make sure the
meta wasn't getting stale so we wanted
to basically generate randomized rosters
for people yeah we just discarded that
eventually yeah I was always a little
worried about that uh particularly in
PvP yeah because if you just get a bad
roster it's true then you're you're just
uh and so the thing is you can play with
all the different randomized rosters and
then choose the ones that you like the
most but yeah it does require some
effort yeah so yeah yeah you would see
people just make a crew throw it away
make your crew throw it away uh and this
way I mean you're gonna have to deal
with the meta yeah but
um I mean it's just different yeah
will make my job a lot harder it will
stay but it's okay it's what people want
it's actually what we want to yeah
um so the the what happens is your
captain comes down and every turn you
get an amount of Cinder you've got to
kind of are our resource and then that
can be used to summon new units you've
got it um down for you yep um and so and
that that Cinder is also like what you
use to use all sorts of powers and stuff
you gotta uh so you have to decide do I
want to put on my power do I want to
bring out new users
um is your list of units you can summon
randomized it is yeah
and yep
um exactly now that's a good
randomization it is um I really like
that it's like you draw cards but you're
drawing units you got it and you can
spend more Cinder to get more units yes
so you're always trading off like do I
want to play with what I have and try to
get those out sooner even if they're not
my perfect unit in this situation or do
I try to like spend that you know spend
to like dig for another unit
so yeah um and people might notice uh
one of the the Charming things about
this is uh
um people really like it actually we
were on the fence at first but we were
we knew we had to do it from day one we
said we're when you pitched it to me I'm
like that's just gonna be so much fun
um it's like little Mini's they'll move
around yep
um you can pick up the minis and look at
them yeah so you can see people's paint
jobs uh-huh so I can see all these guys
yep but they don't they just there's no
articulated animation but of course they
still have characters they wobble around
they wobble yeah yeah I feel like people
like that so we're happy that that
worked out
um let's see what else oh and down here
I have these two ship assists oh those
were in when I played before those were
just in your they were but we've now
they're on cooldown okay so you get them
every X turns oh they're free okay okay
are those randomized or you just get you
I didn't show you that but yeah I kind
of clicked through it yeah they are
randomized uh three you get three pairs
that are randomized at the beginning of
the match okay and you choose one bucket
okay this is our last holdout on making
sure that the The Meta doesn't get stale
so we'll see if people still like it I
think it's working really well I mean it
is a digital game so you can tweak stats
absolutely uh in the middle of things
absolutely how much do you plan to do
that a lot yeah a lot a lot a lot this
game is pretty young I mean we've been
playing a lot yeah but let's say that um
you're out of Early Access yep and you
have a season happen yeah and
something's dominating all right you're
gonna obviously yeah you're gonna be
like all right guys starting next week
yeah
change yeah you have to right yeah you
really have to I mean that's one of the
advantages of digital it is uh I know
things like magic the Gathering are just
having trouble with this right now
because it's like
one of the advantages they have is it's
physical but the big disadvantages all
the other digital games yeah can they
mimic the physical right yeah and they
can move for their meta very quickly to
keep things interesting and exciting but
can Arena Arena probably can't adjust no
reason because they have to mimic the
the print yeah they do have a Arena only
online thing
um that they that they're doing that
with yep okay um okay that's cool so you
can play you can play It's called
Alchemy but oh my gosh that's that's a
crazy path to go down but it is two
versions of the game you have two
versions of the cards you've got a card
that if you play in standard that's one
thing yeah and then uh and yeah yeah
that's really tough yeah
okay so while we've been chatting yeah I
basically brought out this cool little
guy called the snarling yes I had one
remember the snare at work so yes he is
great because he's still here
oh I'm sorry that's not snarling this is
tipu my bad those units look very
similar and we have some problems there
okay never mind I've moved him to the
wrong place I'm gonna be fine
everything's fine all right so what did
we get food so tipu is really awesome
tipu grows over time okay each time he
hits he goes he gets a plus one plus one
permanently okay so this guy is like he
can become a total tank
um so I'm just I'm kind of hanging back
here a little bit because this this unit
here is really tough to break through
it's going to kind of keep me at Bay I
kind of want to get some other cool
units out before I run in
and if there's questions I don't know I
can yeah I'm happy to answer them while
I'm playing some questions yeah
um Adam what do people want to know from
us well uh the first question and I
apologize if my audio isn't great okay
so let us know in the chat if I need to
be adjusted but Alfredo mess says
between moonbreaker and the kickstarter
you've been working on a lot of
Miniatures content yes I have true were
minis a hobby of yours growing up and
are they something you collect
personally so
um number one this is kind of an amusing
coincidence because I've been working on
moon breaker for years and you know
we've also been working on The
Stormlight minis for about a year plus
uh and it just kind of came together
that they both got uh the same month uh
but I did paint minis as a youth yeah
um didn't we all yeah it was one of
those hobbies that I've kind of had to
um to give up because there's just not
enough time yeah
um and nowadays
um my brother's the big mini painter and
I go over with my kids sometimes and we
will paint minis together uh so I have
some Minis on my uh on my in my office
sometime we'll show off the minis that
I've painted they're not very good
um but you know it's a it's a fun little
hobby
um one of those things that I kind of
wish I had time for but people always
ask me about my productivity uh I do
time triage quite a bit and say all
right this is the thing that I have time
for and this is the thing that I don't
yep makes sense I'm amazed you play and
beat as many games as you do ah man I
get to play I get to play like two or
three games a year really is all that I
get to do like this year I have really
only had a chance to play Elden ring uh
and I haven't played a game since I've
been building Ring uh spoiler we didn't
uh we haven't been putting it on my
social media I did finally beat Elden
ring
um I just died to the AI no one's
watching right
Mark curse you making the AI better
sorry continue okay is that when you're
one of your coach yeah yeah I don't know
Mariah okay yeah she's responsible for
all the AI among many men sounds like
her job might be at risk now
he's humiliating me on stream yep that's
that's the game you're the you're the
game creator you don't have to become
the best that's true I have learned that
lesson the hard way yes I remember a uh
um
um one time there's uh this famous magic
player who uh you know was playing
against Richard Garfield okay and he
said you know
it's totally cool that he created the
game but yeah do you hear about the
creator of basketball and how good he
was yeah right no because that's not how
yeah true true that's not how it works
the skills two different skills
necessarily yeah absolutely and one
impedes on the other two yeah because
the more you play the more you to get
good you don't have time to make it so
um should we take another question yeah
yeah uh this next one is from lodaroo I
think they say how are they planning to
oh yeah how are they planning to
counteract the potential NSFW or
inappropriate paint jobs good questions
so I can't remember exactly where we
landed on that we have talked about it a
lot oops um I'm going to show you what
we have currently we have a report I
believe the report player feature is in
here
uh things have been going in pretty
quickly so I haven't actually seen it
recently but let me just see if it is
here
there should be a way to basically just
say report this player for a bad paint
job and then on the back end it goes to
our customer support team thank you
Crafton they can do this kind of stuff
small company like unknown worlds could
not have done that let me just see I
think oh I'm in Skirmish okay it's not
actually not here because I'm in
Skirmish but there's basically a report
player option so yeah we're gonna have
to keep tweaking it it's not going to be
done yet Max McGuire the main programmer
technical director on this project and
my co-founder also wrote this really
cool thing so our tech support people
can see the 3D model in a web browser so
they can just when people report they
can basically click a link and they see
the 3D model with the paint job on it
and then decide is this okay or not so
yep we got we got a plan in place
hopefully it's enough if not we'll add
more
Colin Harvey says did Brandon have any
direct contributions to the mechanics of
the game is there anything that is
solely a game mechanic because of his
input Cinder is the closest one right I
mean yeah uh I know that a lot of the
powers yeah of the units yeah because I
designed a culture and you're like oh
explain to me this culture and I'd be
like well you know they are warding and
protecting and they you know they Revere
life and you're like all right I'm gonna
design yes unit yes just use that power
set yeah derive powers from the
adjectives you've given yes yes that's
true and so there was a whole bunch of
that yeah um but I mean yeah I mean
exactly good example right like uh in my
initial pitch one of my very first
pitches is
um for a somewhat roguish character you
see these a lot we want to do a space
fantasy you see this style of character
a lot and I'm like they always get out
of the scraps they always you know they
always survive well this one didn't yeah
uh he and his wife and he's a Han Solo
character he's still mouthing off about
how cool he is he's gonna mouth off how
cool he is but the whole joke is a he
actually died yeah uh he's a hologram
that cool yeah um this is uh and you
built the powers for him around the idea
of oh he's a hologram
um and he's going to you know like I
designed all these captains and you
built them to do their things and you
know what's really cool you probably
don't know this but this is a cool
example his he creates sleeper Minds
which are you know he throws little
Minds out there the way that they work
you know they basically detonate after
they arm they detonate when anything any
when anytime they touch anything right
including Zacks
he blows himself up with his own minds
it's not it doesn't it's not rare so
it's very thematically perfectly with
him and his backstory right so there was
only one Captain I designed that you had
trouble building uh powers for
um or yeah what's that was that Astra or
I can't remember no no no uh it might be
the one we took out and replaced with
another one oh yes coming up in a future
season yes yes
um and so yeah which we're not going to
talk about right now no but now you did
add the Frog we did the artist no no not
this like was it the artist like that
yeah the artist I designed Astra and
then like I remember like the next week
you're like can she
and I'm like sure she could have a pet
frog and you're like can she write on it
because yeah we've designed it her so
that she jumps around all over the place
I'm like you know what I can work with a
giant frog this is something that's
really funny because it the artist you
know one of the concept artists I can't
remember who it was created this it was
just one of the sketches and everyone
loved the Frog hands down yeah it was
just we could just ignore all the other
sketches right so we knew we had to do
the Frog yeah and then just basically
designed the character around it I mean
the powers so astra's whole thing is
she's the the daughter of one of the
greatest Generals in military Minds in
history
um and I won't give you spoilers on her
story but you know it's hard to not live
in the shadow yeah of uh of such a such
a great parent yeah uh and that's kind
of her base concept yep
um so so the Frog does give her Airborne
so that was something that came directly
from it so she can jump over obstacles
and you can see it well the Frog wasn't
mine but I love the Frog and then once
we go once we start rolling with it it
was like okay now she's got to jump and
I mean I uh I she has a what I like
about this is
um I like that the captains all have
very different play Styles they do uh
and they do that because now that you
can build your own roster yeah you're
gonna be adding a lot of the same units
yeah but you're gonna build around your
captain and hopefully by building around
your captain you will then be building
in a different way you're an Astra
player you know yes you're an astro
player you need other things to be tanks
perhaps yep um whereas if you're playing
you've got a built-in exactly yep uh and
he can protect all his other units with
the stackable damage protection yes and
this is that this Stacks like crazy so
someone has two good Advantage power has
uh stayed uh I think all of his powers
have stayed did you see no I don't know
these are probably these are probably a
little bit Yeah like rally wasn't in
there so did you notice we re-themed
these at least for now as more nightly
yeah I don't know if it's really working
but I think it's about right yeah we
might have to change it uh so it's still
ears thing uh since I said what the
other two's thing is yeah is extelior is
a giant death robot who uh recently
became self-aware and is looking for
purpose uh and has lack attached onto
Noble codes from the past
as something to give him a Guiding Light
of how you be you know created for
Destruction and death but try to find
some purpose yeah Redemption yep yeah so
he's trying to write his rungs from his
previous life but he's still he's still
a death robot you know he's not going to
write his wrongs by going and talking to
people yeah or like making a farm right
right he's not going to go you know yeah
the the cholaki Bots they're out there
uh you know they're gonna they're gonna
have their farms and things like that he
just can't do that yep uh but he can be
like all right maybe there's a way to
walk this uh this balance uh between uh
what I was created to do and what I want
to be yep excellent should we take
another question yes uh Baird Rock Brown
says can we get some lore and backstory
and is there a story mode oh we should
we haven't even talked about that yet
all right okay so
um
um oh yeah let's just start should we
just go in yeah here's how you get your
lore uh well your story yeah
you ready should we just do it yeah
hopefully you guys can hear this
we'll only do this for a few minutes
okay um maybe I'll just scrub ahead yeah
do something
all right you should not give too much
because he could be true salary uh so
this specific still you're talking
about this is my concept yeah from the
the get-go yep
um I pitched the whole team on this
which is having in-game audio dramas
that you can listen to what what that
will introduce the characters so you're
gonna be painting right yeah you're
gonna go and you're gonna be like I'm
gonna go paint yeah we'll just go back
to the beginning hit play and close this
I wanna I wanna paint my dudes uh so
but I want to be doing something I have
a friend
um Micah Captain demo from Stormlight he
would play uh World of Warcraft
and he would we should probably pause
that yeah probably yeah okay yeah not
just trailer and they can't really hear
it yeah um so he would play World of
Warcraft uh and he would always listen
to Loveline while he was doing so
yeah pretty funny and I would always
walk in I'm like why why I didn't play
MMOs right
um I do not have time for an MMO like
why aren't you playing the game why are
you listening to this thing he's like
well you know I've got to kill 1700 rats
in order to maybe get this uh this rare
drop that I want uh so I'm gonna you
know do that and that and Loveline I'm
like yeah that's actually kind of cool
it's multitasking right
um and I thought ah it's really too bad
that World of Warcraft doesn't just have
you know audio dramas about the
characters so that you can be playing
and stay immersed while you're playing
um oh what kind of brush do you so
stipple
ah we decided that now that's cool we
hired as an aside we hired I don't know
if you know this we hired all
professional Miniatures painters did
Jeff to paint all these and one of the
first things they asked for was a
stipple so we just had to add it can
continue yeah continue
um so
um I like how I mean so these were all
painted in the system yeah everything
you see here's painted with this tool
yeah um so
I had this idea in my head for years
years and years and years uh and I once
uh told some friends at uh Bad Robot
which is JJ Abrams company this idea I
had uh and I think honestly that's why
they introduced us I think because we
got a perfect fit for it on this game
and yeah and they're like you're going
to be spending a lot of time painting
you don't say yep
um and so they came to me and said
there's this cool game you want to come
come uh listen to these guys and one of
the very first pitches I made to you
guys was hey I have this idea uh no one
has done this
um I think you should have audio dramas
like yeah in game that you can click
play on and you can listen to while
you're uh painting your Minis and things
and it happened and now it yeah we're
finally like legit came together Audio
Drama is written by
uh Dan Wells my uh my Intrepid co-host
um on intentionally blank
um I came up with the outlines and the
characters and he uh wrote the audio
dramas themselves uh and they are
fantastic and we are they really turn it
well you guys being able to that's how
you're gonna get to know the characters
yep so you said can we get some lore I
want you to listen to the auto dramas
yeah it's a full story right yeah it's
full story now when you say
um I use lore differently than you ah
yes um I use lore for any story in a
game anything related to
um so narrative uh like ambient and all
that stuff I just generally
I see uh you're right I should probably
listen to your terminology no no I
should listen to yours oh no
um so but if you want to get like uh the
The Narrative of each character uh if
you want to find out you know the lore
behind a character yeah listen to their
Audio Drama right
um
and
um you're welcome by the way this is
your exfolio from now on my exterior is
yep wow that is that is something I mean
I was yeah I was limited on time uh yeah
uh are you bragging about how awesome
that is I just I think it's just gonna
be it's gonna be really funny to see you
play online and people recognize you
because you got the pink head exterior
but don't worry you can never change you
actually can still you can but you
wouldn't would you no just go back I
would never go back to so boring this
incredible paint job done
you know he's he's searching for himself
and how to express himself yep and what
he's come up with is my face should be
pink yep and a yellow bandana
um so yeah so the thing about the lore
is or the story we're releasing those
audio dramas every month yeah so we're
probably gonna have to skip a couple
months but basically every month your
terminology is better than mine okay
okay yep
um and so
we'll be doing the audio dramas
um you can get other lore by reading
about the pieces
um and just kind of paying attention
we'll be adding a lot more of that sort
of thing yeah um like right now there's
not a ton of it yeah
um there's not you know like uh a ton of
little unlockable hints and things like
that but you know we will we will be
adding a lot more yep and we have the
cool thing is Brandon has built this
entire universe like huge documents to
describe like everything in the game so
it's now it's just up to us to start
building game building the game around
it which of course we've already done
but like we're going to be dribbling it
out over time we started with this lore
tab here and then the first Audio Drama
we've got other audio dramas in
production right now they'll be
launching during season one now this is
really cool because this is
um this is cholec yep but it's not
cholec
um people it's uh it's a giant plant
it's a giant plant from their home Moon
yep so those things now uh that is
pretty cool yeah
um I'm glad you did like you we're
always saying you want to do lots of
beasties yeah but you're also saying it
was kind of hard to get beasties of the
right size yeah um challenge so I'm glad
to see
um obesity in here I think we did it I
think we actually managed to get the
because you know Miniatures games have
they get really exciting when you have
those giant like bigatures or whatever
yes they're really big ones we couldn't
go as big as like a giant Jeep next to
all these little tiny units but I feel
like we more or less got the scale so
they they can have different Footprints
yeah only two we have small and large
but yeah but yeah hopefully it's enough
it starts to get more difficult when you
have more than that well in our uh our
battlefields are not you know they're
pretty quad-based they're very tiny yep
um how many battlefields do are we
launching so we're launching with four
and then we're gonna be Yep they're
gonna be releasing along with the auto
dramas we're going to be releasing new
maps I knew you were worried about that
um well they didn't come together until
recently so what you see now actually
looks a lot better than it did even a
few months ago so yeah you have me
asking lots of questions about what you
finally decided now you're going yeah
are they going to be randomized features
to the maps uh there are not at launch
okay we might do that later Oops I did
this wrong there's no people online yet
because the game's not used to playing
against other people I am I am in Dev
yeah exactly we're very competitive
[Music]
do you guys have like a leaderboard
so Fabrizio does have access to the back
end stats so he can give us the ELO
ranking of any person and sometimes just
does a little screenshot and pastes it
into chat which causes quite an uproar
because then that's usually me saying
there's there's a bug here right and
everyone else saying this looks great so
um I just wanted to show you this
environment here because yeah it's such
a cool like I feel like we capture is
this like a methadorian
okay yeah look at ships
oh man I imagined this uh and now they
actually now they're here man we're
gonna have to find some way to get
people ships they can paint oh my gosh I
think we're gonna be able to do that
yeah yeah I do think like where like the
show
what we want to do is when the game
starts right now the captain can just
teleports down but wouldn't it be cool
if you saw your ship come in and you get
to paint your [ __ ] and you got to paint
it you got to like buy the ship and then
you got to like you know you'd see the
ship arrive and then your captain comes
down and then when you win you basically
go back up your ship and take off right
and it's this whole expressive thing
it's just like a cosmetic thing that I
think people really love but I want a
ship right yeah me too well we'll
hopefully get to it
um look at my sweet exterior
I mean your sweet exterior it's amazing
come on yeah yeah not enough green to
clash with that pink I think no but he's
very readable uh yeah he is yeah yeah
and it's easy for the Zacks oh I like
that Zach's kind of floats yeah Isn't
that cool yeah yeah
um hologram pad yep um
more questions
um but we did get a question regarding
the audio dramas yeah I'm wondering if
they'll be subtitled or available in
another way to read go ahead and show it
yeah we do boom they don't match up as
it plays but the text is all localized
so you can actually read it
um I don't I'm trying to think if we
actually do if I switch to a different
language it'll kind of cut me out of
here I don't think we actually display
it on screen although we might actually
display the text as well
um we're going to do better at that
because we support a lot of languages
already but we want to like we don't
support it fully throughout the game yet
but over time you know once we're out of
either you know on the way out of Early
Access I hope we can do that
um you can also get the audio dramas uh
as they launch on your favorite podcast
yeah you don't have to buy the game you
can just listen to the world yeah the
story if you want yeah
um
sex
Katie Payne art as well as many others
in the chat wants to know if the game
will ever move off steam to say
something like the Nintendo switch or
other future points we would love to go
on every platform that you guys want it
on that's our basically popularity is
going to determine how much we can do
with it exactly right it's been designed
to go yeah everywhere I'm actually you
know glad to hear that you're charging
for it yeah I know there were lots of
conversations yeah and once you charge
for a game
your monetization gets much less
predatory and uh I just I like that yeah
we're not we're not fans of Preparatory
games obviously I mean who is but
there's a lot of pressure on games you
know these days to use a lot of uh
predatory monetization and yep that's uh
that's uh that's a thing right like it's
a delicate balance it is a delicate
balance because and I don't necessarily
blame game developers because
as you've talked to me about before like
yeah how many people's lives are you in
charge of and if your game doesn't make
money then they just all lose their jobs
that you're like one game away from it's
so true
um uh and that's that's a weird thing
about the gaming industry that uh I've
talked to Charlie a lot like my field
um if I read a bad book that's bad right
yeah but my back list continues to sell
um people are still interested in my
books and things like that we are not
one bad book away from disaster sure
sure I'm like 10 years of consistently
being bad away from disaster uh but in
the video game industry like you know
you you are spending you know Millions a
year of just maintaining yeah yeah um
and if you make a bad game then it's
just it's all over it's all over yeah
well that's why we wanted to with
moonbreaker we wanted to make a game
that we could support for decades yeah
that's kind of the whole idea of this
game so we don't have to get stuck in
that trap oh like I'm stuck right here
oh I can't move no no jailbreak got me
this is exactly where exterior wants to
be he just needs to get healed true but
yes I kind of don't want I'm like low
enough health I don't actually want to
fight him but with a [ __ ] she can
actually she can take him out I didn't
wasn't my wasn't my plan but
goodbye
okay good you notice that whenever a
unit dies he gives hope basically right
this rally he gets to Shield the hope to
a random Ally and so she he gave her the
right because you only got two units on
right now and it could be him too but um
kind of thematic too
um yes more questions
uh the next question is from Joel
deschane he says uh regarding features
of painting if I paint the minis in my
squad purple will they be better at
stealth or faster if I paint them red
something along those lines okay no we
want that to be totally creative and not
not gameplay affecting
yeah that's I don't even know how would
we do that I mean you could do it but it
would be it would be dangerous maybe a
bad idea because uh then your painting
skill determines your playing style
which is really a dangerous place to be
in yeah uh it's it gives you the
Fortnight problem right yeah it's like
fortnite is really hard to get into
until they've made some of these new
game modes the no bills and stuff
because you can't just be good at
building and you can't just be good at
being an FPS player you have to be good
at both otherwise you can't play
fortnite yep and just adding that extra
skill proficiency made it you know like
the experts loved it more yeah but it
was it's so hard for new players it is
and if you had to be both good at
painting and yeah yeah yeah and for us
we just I don't even know how we would
do that if we want yeah how you would
Implement it's like really like what I
mean it's just a little red what does
that mean yeah I suppose what you could
do now I'm just thinking you know like a
game designer you could say all right
apply this base coat and it adds a
certain thing to your unit yeah if you
paint over that and however way you want
to so you could do that yeah I shouldn't
dismiss it there might be a way we could
do it as long as it wasn't skill based
as long as it goes all right I'm gonna
shade this
um all of my units you know start with a
purple base coat
um and I'm going to indicate that's what
I've done and it's actually not a
terrible idea to just okay we're working
on it now that that's like a that's like
a season 12 sort of thing uh exactly
once uh yeah exactly
[Music]
next question from twitch sprig Leaf
says what are the reasons
and are there any media outlets in
Universe okay so what are the what the
first what are the reaches okay what are
the reaches go oh yeah so the reaches so
this kind of comes where
um
when Charlie came to me uh what he said
is I want something that is science
fantasy
um and if you don't know what science
fantasy is uh Dune is my favorite
science fantasy it's a science fiction
with a bit of a Fantastical element to
it uh so Dune Star Wars
um uh anything where you've got
um spaceships with
um psychics I mean uh Skyward is a space
fantasy a science fantasy
um that's what they're looking for and
the other thing he said said is I kind
of want it to be more hopeful
um more optimistic meaning a lot of
gaming Miniatures
um uh live in the Grim dark future where
there is only war ah which is a
um you know not throwing any Shade
that's awesome but it's been done so
much if you're gonna find um a voice for
yourself you look at what is dominant
and you say all right let's do something
different yeah uh and so meanwhile I had
this idea
for a universe it was called Soul burner
you can probably go back many years in
my state of the sandersons and see me
mentioning
um something called Soul burner from
before I met Charlie
um and this is for the basic concept was
for a science Fantasy World
um Universe where it was one giant
like red giant type Star right
um dimmer than a star but brighter than
say Jupiter
um surrounded by uh just dozens and
dozens of moons
set up in a really complicated orbit
that um that uh requires some
maintenance some mystical maintenance to
keep it all going
um it's all this really intricate
machine of all these moons spinning
around
um and moving past one another and what
I loved about this
um as a setting was this kind of little
city-states yeah right like yeah we're
not talking little prince style moons
but kind of like that like smaller than
our moon one city Two city-sized Moons
um that were spinning around and
sometimes you would they would come in
close contact with an enemy or your
trade routes would be different uh and
the other weird thing that I decided
that I wanted for this is I wanted air
in space
um Star Wars does this other thing where
half the time there's air in space and
half the time there isn't I didn't know
that uh where if you go out in space in
Star Wars you'll suffocate yeah but
ships Bank yeah right right using um
like they they use uh fluid dynamics
um uh and uh aerodynamics and things
like this for flying right right and
there's in uh in Star Wars there's
sometimes gravity in space sometimes not
when Princess Leia gets sucked out into
space there's no gravity but when a ship
turns everyone Falls sideways
um I'm like you know I don't like this
we can do better we can do better yeah
uh and so what I said is I'm it's a
feature there is actually air in space
you can take you can get in a ship that
doesn't have a canopy and you can see
you can sail or fly yeah between two of
these moons uh and so you can use like
uh you can get on a giant pterodactyl
thing yeah and you can fly very slowly
between moons they are close enough that
you know you could you could do it it
would take you months but you can do it
um and you can breathe in space
um and while there's artificial Gravity
the the sun provides the main source of
gravity so you don't need artificial
gravity for your ship you can just you
know stay on top of your uh your your
little you build yourself a barge yeah
and you can stay on top of it and as
long as it's between you and the and the
uh thing and you've got Cinder to keep
you uh and he grabbed up yep you're fine
yeah um right and I built this whole
cool complex system uh I had like I had
like 5 000 words to work on it before I
realized this could just not fit in the
cosmere there was no way I could get
this to go in the cosmere I
um and so I shelved it like I will find
something to do with this and I didn't
really even build it first for a book I
built it more of just a world and a
concept that was really fun for me
um and
I had it sit there I explored maybe
doing some sort of movie with it for a
while uh and then when you came to me
and you were talking about what you
wanted I'm like this fits I've got this
thing yeah yeah it's called Soul burner
yeah
um and let's talk about it and I pitched
it to you you had another pitch too we
didn't we didn't so I had two pictures
for you
um one was a code named Brink one was
called code name uh and Brink was kind
of small scale uh because I knew you
were doing a squad based Majors
um thing and I said here's the two
options one is more expensive yeah uh is
more difficult
um but it gets you more of this Star
Wars Universe you want you're gonna have
to you're gonna have to deal with the
fact that there'll be dozens of moons
with potentially dozens of different
species and uh cultures and things like
that
um or you can take this other one that's
that's more
um more narrowed focused and you
immediately wanted the big expansive
yeah that's why it takes us five years
to make a game um so this uh this
setting is is really big there's a whole
lot going on there's a whole lot behind
the scenes there is a giant interesting
cool plot that we're not even going to
talk about yeah it's going to be a
little while yeah
establish them all first and then we'll
start talking about what the actual plot
uh is and you'll Discover it through the
uh through the the audio dramas what's
going on and things like that uh and so
this is this is what we're doing the
reaches is my word uh for all of this
together basically it can replace the
Universe
um it is all of these moons and the Sun
and all the space between them is the
reaches yep that's the longest most
complete answer you're ever going to get
very in line with Brandon's other yes
that's how we do it this is how we roll
on Earth you know you gotta answer it
fully yeah I was actually that was half
what I was expecting so you get long
answers today things this is a sprick
leap has been playing a lot so he's like
oh yeah he gets he gets the full answer
how you doing here I feel you know your
strategy is actually the thing that we
wanted to do yeah it's more or less
working yeah yeah so this guy yeah he's
giving me tons of Health right and
staying away from everyone and my
exterior is basically just running and
killing everyone right the problem is I
don't really have a lot of offense at
the moment yeah your other your other
things are
the exterior has as Al so he does hit
everybody and that was a mistake yes bar
beat the captain then you win yep oh
look at that that was actually really
bad for you the captain is your golden
snitch uh if you can if you can beat the
enemy Captain you you ought to win and
what he just pretty much gave me that
win so I guess we're still working on
this but thank you Mar oh wait okay
that's that's gonna save him so that so
severia uh she will reduce you can see
her ability in the upper left the next
damage that unit takes is zero so I want
to hit him with if I had a really like a
chip damage kind of thing I would use it
unfortunately all I have is this
that'll knock that off yeah and then I
can hit everyone but the thing is I'm
stuck in here
but it doesn't matter because I'm just
going to stick him to the ground now
he's stuck I just have to wait one turn
I'm gonna get my free reinforcement
not free but um I'm just gonna bring
this guy in case I need him and he's
stuck and he's this is the little guy
that gets stronger everything yeah it is
but he's dead unless you can kill me
unless he can do 14 damage he's going to
try to kill my super healer that
basically just this guy just heals my
captain yeah
as much as you didn't spend you got it
so I can just use up it actually doesn't
use it yeah yeah okay but you have to
save it for next turn yeah yeah so
that's cool yeah it is pretty cool and
now he dead
this is it take that AI yeah pick that
Mar
[Laughter]
uh okay now I have to win right now but
luckily I will so that's it yep
GG white Fisher says could you tell us
about one of the times where there was a
disagreement between both sides uh maybe
in terms of World building game
Direction Etc and how do I solve it yeah
go ahead I'll take that I mean basically
I would I mean Brandon is like a super
pro so I mean if there's a disagreement
like if we give feedback on something
Yeah it's you're just super flexible
you're just like okay well here's three
other options that are all equally as
good and once in a while I'll push back
right I'll be like all right yeah true
um there's never a uh you know yeah yeah
that's not how we roll no um but if you
come back and say here this isn't
working for me yeah my goal will be give
to give you options but I'll sometimes
push back and say I don't think you
quite get it here's the advantage of
this one uh but if you come back and say
it really doesn't work yeah I mean the
the thing I've been saying you're you're
going to hear this over and over again
if you watch the interviews with us
about this
um the difference
here is well it's it's not even that
different actually
um world building must
um accentuate gameplay not the other way
around right
um now the thing is Brandon's not diva
in other words
this is the way this is the same in
books though yeah your world building
has to accentuate your story Your World
building shouldn't be an app to itself
although the characters even in this
case were subservient to the game
characters in in video clips I've played
so I have a fondness I'm not going to
mention any names but I have I have gone
through and played a bunch of games that
have had um authors involved in them
right and I feel like I can tell when
the author was in charge yeah and when
the author was there to help someone who
knew how to make games fun okay because
the game with a great story but terrible
gameplay is a bad game yeah but a game
with a really weak story but awesome
gameplay is all it's a great game great
game yeah right uh and I do think that
great story and great gameplay is better
like I I can point to
um I don't know the Borderlands Series
right yeah yeah uh Borderlands 2 is just
awesome because the the character
writing and the story is really good
Borderlands one they didn't have time
for the story they're both really fun
games yep the Borderlands one didn't
flop because the story was weak right
everyone just said it's really fun by
the way the story is weak right then
they improved it that's a great game and
yeah but it's a great game yeah they're
both great games yeah the second's a
little better but it's not like adding a
fantastic Story made it 10 times better
yeah it just incremented it just
slightly better they're both great games
and I will say for us went to you know
when the story is pulling in One
Direction the gameplay is pulling in
another that's where we the only thing
we really notice that is when we're
trying to make our campaign mode yes and
we basically couldn't resolve that
conflict because the more story we added
basically you know you you create a
story with structure this is me
pretending I'm Brandon uh you create a
story with structure you create your
characters and you set your you know
your your plot your plot points or your
Beats and you try to figure out how in
our campaign can we create this speech
and this is this is never something that
I really wanted uh there were internal
elements that were like yeah must have a
campaign mode yeah and I I the most
frustrating part about the whole
experience yeah was designing like
exterior story I had designed it like
three different ways to try to match the
shifting views internally of what the
campaign that was a really difficult
time it was so hard yeah and it was so
frustrating yeah because I'm like all
right I'll rebuild this whole story so
it matches your new vision of the
campaign mode we should have just asked
it earlier um you came in and like hey
I've developed this thing called cargo
run yeah right we should show by the way
um and it turns um the Miniatures game
in to slay the spire and I'm like
tell me more yeah exactly the roguelike
and uh that was super exciting for me
and so to close that last point for on
my side the we basically couldn't get
both great story and great gameplay
dovetailed together so what we ended up
by doing is doing great gameplay on its
own which is of course the multiplayer
and then I'll show you the cargo run so
the cargo run is like our single player
where the whole game goes off the rails
in a cool way like slave Aspire or
um dungeon run in Hearthstone but then
and then our story is like there's no
branching it is it's not it's not a
player it's Audio Drama the problem that
we kept running into was this idea of
like I pitched this idea for audio
dramas yeah I love the idea yeah and
then internally there were certain
elements are like all right we'll cut
the Audio Drama into five pieces that's
the thing but
I don't want to stop like my argument
was always you never want to stop
gameplay yeah to go to do some story
right you want to you want to have your
story and do whatever you want to do it
yeah you don't but then if you didn't go
listen to One chunk of the story and
continued your uh your oh it's like a
nightmare and now you're playing and now
you're playing a story that you don't
understand you don't have context for it
if you haven't listened to it you had
yeah uh it was it was all a big mess and
it got so much easier yeah when uh we
asked it completely and Charlie's like
what do you want to do Brandon yeah here
is a simple version of these audio
dramas yeah that will really lay out who
your characters are it's so much easier
it's so much better and you're like I
just want to do cargo run I'm like yeah
this is so much better we're we're both
so much happier uh and it wasn't like
you and I are arguing there was there
was another trying to make it work yeah
yeah well yeah it was pushing of course
of course we all wanted the best thing
yeah one of the best things and we have
this when you have like a boatload of
Brandon world and Laura you want that to
be throughout you want that to be to be
baked throughout the entire game so
that's the you know you it would be
great to have story inside okay I'll
show you I mean it's not gonna I think
this card run shouldn't have story yeah
I think that's a shortcuts right I think
you should unlock little tidbits sure
and things like that that expand the
story that you've already listened to
um and so we don't do it yet but I think
we should I think that we should but
yeah you know this is one of these
things Early Access yeah exactly this is
early days so with cargo run as I
understand you can correct me yeah
things have changed oh here's your
assistant yep I saw that three buckets
of randomized buckets yes yep
um for us you should always take that
Health one uh yeah yeah yeah the only
thing the thing is only works if he has
five health or less which kind of fits
his character but it's dangerous never
mind about that and look at this guy we
have special bosses for cargo run oh all
unique yeah you may maybe you haven't
seen these well I knew you were talking
about it yeah I have them they're all in
happy you did it so you're gonna base
basically fit a fight
a a set of randomized
um cruise with a boss you got it uh to
fight your way to the end of the cargo
run in increasing difficulty yeah it
gets harder and harder and harder and
it's really hard each one you win you're
gonna get to choose some sort of way to
uh so what we did you haven't seen what
we did there I'm going to show you we
wanted to skip the whole in-game out of
game thing okay most most games would
just say after you beat it choose like a
batch of upgrades or choose an upgrade
we wanted to do it in game in map
boom so you're you have to position to
get basically upgrades come down in map
and you have to navigate to it or use
your positional powers to get the crates
to the units okay and the way you choose
it and that that goes the the crate
itself opens up and is there like
multiple options in there uh there's no
multiple options each crate is its own
unique uh upgrade okay and depending
which unit picks it up we'll upgrade
that unit okay so you can find out
what's in the crate and then you can see
what it is okay okay and this is how you
recruit new crew also okay so some of
those traits will just have a crew like
this one's detonia okay if I get that I
get to Tonya right but the thing is the
boss is smart that's like leaning into
what the game is doing that's exactly it
like one of your big advantages for this
over something like this buyers yeah the
battlefield that you can position on
that's it so why exactly why not just do
it like look at this this Vortex beam
yeah I'm just going to move I'm gonna
move myself there and then pull
everything to you yep of course I'm
gonna hit my own bomb but look now I
touch the crate now look free dytonia
yes here she comes oh she set off the
bottom that wasn't a good move but uh
that was really funny one of the
questions that we've all I've had is if
you lose a unit is it gone it's gone and
that's cool too which is great because
that's the XCOM thing right because now
with these cargo you can you can make
individual units super powerful you know
what's also cool is you added cargo to
the cargo red it had to be there come on
it had to it was like you named it cargo
run you're you're gonna sound so smart
really like hey get the cargo you named
it cargo run before there was Cargo in
it we did yeah I don't need I don't even
remember we were talking about Smugglers
like going between planets or things I
guess so and bring a thing to a planet
like that was the original kind of
concept that's why yeah is there a
visualization for the different places
you're going
um there's not yeah no
because that was that would be some
tricky things about it was uh was that
so yeah we have of course we've created
the whole map like we know what the
reaches look like yep do the players get
to see it yet not yet but hopefully we
will so how do you know which level of
the cargo run you're on so it doesn't
actually show it but when you're out of
the game you can see it's like one two
three four five there's five moons in a
row five minutes so this is the first
match it's the first Moon it doesn't
show in here
um but that's why this guy is level one
but he's still super dangerous he's got
a five attack and look at this anytime
he touches someone it does damage to
everyone that he touches and then when
he when he attacks he stuns all nearby
units including himself okay oh really
yeah he's kind of a Goofy character yeah
so sometimes you want to get him to stun
himself but if he gets close to you it
can be game over like like pretty much
instantly you have to be very very
careful with him
so I'm going to keep everyone away and
in fact I'm actually just going to pull
him as far away as possible that's not
very far
but I'm gonna do it anyways
and get this guy to block yeah that life
one you have to be at five or less life
yep real hard but it's better for Crews
so she's almost there yeah so he just
did damage to Chuck and Co and he
stunned him oh my God and he stunned
himself
luckily oh wait what is happening that
might have been a bug what just happened
oh he did
interesting we huh I can see that being
a bug or not a bug he attacked even
though he was stunned because he's got
two abilities
uh deal two damage to any unit it
collides with but normally that would be
when he's not when he's stunned right so
I could see that going either way
um anyways that's the fun of making a
game like this I mean due to damage to
anything you collided with seems like it
should happen even if you're stunned
right you ran into people it's not like
you attacked them you just smash them
yeah yeah his attack his animation is
that he attacks but you're right I mean
that's kind of we'll have to figure have
to think about that one all right okay
next question so we have three very
common questions that I want to throw
out you guys okay uh the first one is
can you import export paint jobs to and
from other players not currently it's
probably the most requested feature I
have a very strong feeling we will be
adding something like that at some point
not in the not too distant future
um can you 3D print your own minis from
the game ah that is also one of your
most it's fairly it's up there
um you can't currently but it's early
access so yeah maybe we'll we'll
definitely think about that one
and will you sell minis from the game
another common one
um we might uh my only issue is I just
don't want to generate a lot of plastic
for the oceans so that that's my only
issue because
we sold like a million minis all of a
sudden there's like a million minis like
they're eventually that we're all gonna
drink so uh just if anyone knows of any
biodegradable Miniatures production
methods I would love to know I don't
know if it would hold us up but it's
definitely something to think about
something to think about yeah did make
subnautica yeah exactly this is like a
passion exactly as a scuba diver I
appreciate that passion you're welcome
I'm screwdriver too oh I can do some
tricks
look at this okay now look at this armor
plates so these are relics which is like
to slay the Spire yeah right and I know
you love slay I do love slay so this
gives all my crew plus three Health just
permanent just permanently for a whole
run so like I have to get that you gotta
but that's got 10 lives so can someone
can destroy it so before you get it they
actually so this is a bug we shouldn't
be displaying the health we wanted to
make them be destroyable but they're not
currently okay so they have health but
can't be destroyed yet yep the problem
is they will not ever be able to be
destroyed maybe not ever the problem is
if I just go grab it I'm in range of
this guy and he's gonna stun me and then
keep me stunned so I actually just can't
walk over and get it if I use my gravity
disc I mean I might be able to pull
myself into it but look I'm actually
pulling him into it too which is the
same problem so I think what I might be
able to do is this and then you just
pull it to you I can go back here
I should have attacked first okay now I
got the large armor plates now she's got
the plus Health right she's stuck though
you were still here but you're not yours
no exactly yeah
give her the lifeline but she's stuck
because that's what jailbreak does he
pins touching units so but I can break
him apart and which I think I'm gonna do
because now she's Tada that black hole
is a really handy it's really powerful
so and she's a 10 Health to Tonya I
don't want to lose her now
so let's do [ __ ] that I actually had
that piece before but it was not her oh
oh it was like some ns2 yeah
cool keep the questions coming yeah
um the next one is Brandon are there any
plans to add any of your other
characters to this game oh so they've
discussed it yeah what's that yeah yeah
we have not uh not really discussed it
um it depends on it's really going to
depend on how
um
how strong
the uh unknown worlds team wants to keep
their lore
um meaning like there's no problem
adding kelsier to fortnite because
fortnite does not did you do that yeah
we did that's pretty cool uh fortnite's
lore is uh yeah every anybody can be in
this right yeah um I built
um this to be self-contained and I did
not work in Earth references
um I did not work in references to any
of my books or cosmere I worked in two
tiny references to subnautica
um I didn't even know that yeah you know
about one of them I do uh yeah
um but um
you might know about both I'll tell you
yeah okay okay
um just two little kind of references
um potentially to they could say maybe
somewhere in this universe subnautica
and you know uh all the things it's like
it's it's it would have to be a
completely different star and things
like this but right the reaches might be
some weird uh part of the universe that
somebody is in uh that will be up to uh
the unknown worlds team yeah but when I
build something I like to
with its own Integrity yeah and so I
didn't I didn't build any references and
there's no plans in my mind to add any
of my characters because I think it
would you know undermine the entirety
yeah now it that's not to say that that
um that fortnite has no Integrity right
right if unknown worlds eventually
decides hey you know we like having
references to other things we are
putting it in uh the the same universe
as this then maybe yep so just no plans
yet no plans it's got to find its own
legs first yeah we got to figure out
what what we're doing this and really
this is up to what the team feels like
um they want to do
yeah I think we just got to see how it
goes yep
that's a good question it is a good
question something we should have
thought we'll see if people can
eventually like there's no way right now
to find the references
um to uh subnautica as they are they are
not the sort of thing that's going to
show up in the game I lost my Daytona my
10 Health to Tonya oh she's not dead yet
Mars This is on you finish her exactly
and this is why you don't want to pick
up upgrades because sometimes you lose
something along the way you might even
just lose but in this case I'm actually
probably not even going to beat this
first round
too busy talking yeah I'm just kind of
playing automatically instead of you
know it is it is a hard thing it's
actually surprisingly hard yeah yeah you
have to really think in this mode what
kind of learning curve do you think this
game has and this is a question from me
not from anyone in the gym yeah it seems
um
I mean the rules are really simple so I
mean there's you know we have like you
know all the units move the same speed
basically they all have the same range
basically
um there's just you know every unit just
has their one ability except the
captains which have three it's pretty
simplified I'd like to think that's
pre-simplified but um but a lot of
variants that's what we're hoping for
you want the complexity coming in the
combination it's the combinations right
because when you start putting them on a
on a map and then you're thinking about
this guy the order of attacks right like
this guy can pin everyone so do I want
him in the front or the back can I move
him behind you know the order that you
that you take for the with your moves
really affects this is that Sentinel
locked in place it is yeah but I'm gonna
give him rapid fire in a second oh it
doesn't work oh but I can go uh because
he just has an ability this is an
ability not an attack not an attack
right which I'm not sure if that's
great or not but that's what it is yeah
yeah but I could give it you know what's
true it should have a just like if you
move in range of it it auto shoots you
we might or we may or may not have a
unit coming
ah well there you are may or may not be
one of the new cultures I mean that's
amazing it's actually the sort of thing
that you can do again in this sort of
game that is like I love
um I love like magic Arena and aspiring
stuff but you don't have a actual
Battlefield with tactical locations no
right
um and here I guess this is strategic
not tactic yeah no this is tactics this
is tactics strategies yeah is yeah
something cool yeah watch this
so right now he oops oh well that worked
but it should be fine he couldn't hit
anyone but now if I do all well now I
have to double move uh-huh
I think I don't know how many people hit
but I'm gonna double move
there we go oh because it's got the area
of effect
got it that's cool yeah that's pretty
nice
and then it's gonna do a double attack
as well right so you wish that you
picked up the upgrade after you'd summon
more units
because then they actually they still
going forward it's just going forward
it's going forward yeah it's a permanent
thing yeah yeah but there are other
things you could pick up that's like the
unit that picked it up gets plus three
exactly yeah it's so The Relic was just
a little more powerful that relics are
super powerful and you can get a whole
bunch of them so
um the uh
uh wants to know yeah how many things
fall in a in a battle is it how long you
last it keeps so they you want to run
around in circles with an enemy you
don't so they stop and you can see
they've actually stopped okay so this
yeah it has to be that way it has to be
otherwise yeah I would you drag out the
map yeah you drag out the maps and
that's never a fun gameplay mechanic no
although I will say it's hard enough we
probably could continue dropping them
and you probably like look at this guy I
haven't even really hurt him yeah I'm
gonna have but he's he's been healed by
the other guys he have infinite units
but he doesn't okay he's not he's this
is it he's out he's no more here so this
is really going to come down to in fact
I don't have any more either
um so this is it right here
so I have to be very careful
I have to think about this actually he
you can feel one of your units right I
can or yeah but this is just too juicy
look at that uh yep I don't think I'm
gonna how much uh how much Cinder does
it take to use when your ship assists
are they they're free they're just on
cooldown okay so I'm gonna take out
those guys
and she has to hit the captain
now I could do he's got she's got armor
so I guess I'm gonna have to hit there
that's a double attack uh-huh and then
he's gonna get I guess I'll probably go
here first I have to check the movement
range yeah because if he touches my
captain he lost pretty much game over oh
yeah I'm gonna get as far away as
possible I may block there too to make
sure he can't do it oops
why not that's a bug oh clicking the
wrong thing
um and then she's gonna block yep I
don't want to lose her for next round
but I just can't afford to but you're
gonna heal her right I don't have any
more yeah oh I have my lifeline that's
true okay thank you yep yeah I guess
it's probably better do now
given the Stillness even though it's not
going to last
so now I've got a chance now so why did
you attack me Captain rather to remove
the unit that was next to him
um so she so shrapnel has armor so her
attack does two but only would have done
one armor I really I don't really yeah
it's gonna be tough to get rid of that
I've done three but not four because the
armor would have moved one hit of
everything that you did yeah it would
have yeah it would have done so two
damage would have been one because you
had you shot twice for two oh and then
armor goes for every attack yeah that's
what I'm saying yeah okay yeah that I
was figuring that out so you could not
have actually filled that unit no
probably not oh my God what's happening
I wasn't paying attention uh you're uh
bye-bye Arya yeah tell her we love her
yeah this is even if I recover from this
it's going to be tough to continue to
run to keep beating because you've
you've lost so many units I have but
three four five
six seven eight nine actually I can win
right here
so uh they're uh what's the like you
have we have an x-com you can miss right
yep and you can here too and so you were
killed oh stunned
um yep the damage oh crap but
yeah oh I didn't see this but I did I
forgot I did actually have more units I
just wasn't noticing I'm gonna win now
you got one last uh last yeah I saw Zero
here but I actually had more in my
Reserve yeah look at this my poor
Captain so I'll win this but it's gonna
be really surprisingly close oh my gosh
what
what's happening dump does you have
rapid fire what this is the first level
how's the how many of these levels are
there too there's five five and they get
progressively harder so but you get more
upgrades so now I keep my armor plates
and then all my units this is all I have
left and they actually they do get
healed a little bit in between
um and then my captain heals some you
get some cards oh they don't heal they
heal some oh they feel like the amount
of Cinder you have left oh wow yeah look
at this all I have now that seems like
that would be very challenging so you
have to make it through all five all
five wow I mean I I have to say I I beat
cargo run probably like two-thirds of
the time that I play okay so you can you
know but a lot of it is randomized so
you're never gonna know exactly so that
was the first match
all right what else yeah
um from twitch uh anthrus GG says do you
have a favorite culture or unit that you
designed like something that's stuck and
you're like oh I wish they had always
win battles that'd be cool to have some
and some of my books
[Laughter]
um so the problem is we've only revealed
three of the captains and three of the
cultures uh and I think my favorite is
hasn't been revealed yet
um who's your favorite again uh it's the
Bots
of the cultures the witch the the chill
like Bots oh yeah yeah yeah uh gotcha
right yeah and I don't think we've
gotten there we've got we've we're
coming soon the cholecki themselves uh
we revealed the methadori and we've done
the Smugglers uh what would you call the
Smugglers uh the Smugglers Smugglers
yeah
um and so basically you have your wild
card faction uh that is this is all the
pieces we didn't know where we where
they went plus you know we're building a
fun
um space adventure game you gotta have a
pirate faction right yeah absolutely um
so it's a wild card plus Pirates and
that's just really handy to have uh and
then we have our methadori which are
um uh which are space Romans space
Romans yeah uh but armor area control
that kind of stuff the cholex yep uh
like energy life-giving uh everything is
connected yep
um powerful nature yep uh Mesoamerican
uh inspired yep
um so so your favorite unit is one of
the ones that we haven't released yet
yes my favorite cult uh culture because
the units I don't know a lot about the
units yeah right like I have I have
played games with Astra and I've played
games with uh still here and that's it
yep
um I can answer I can answer which one
my favorite unit is I
I mean they're all I'm in love with all
of them but I have to say this one
I love your designs on all of these
I mean yeah man these designs are
incredible I think Joe like are so much
fun I think people like the show like
visually the most so far
um like I had no idea where you're gonna
go with these yeah and they're pretty
out there gone are just amazing it's got
this bug on the end of a fishing line
yeah and yeah and he's like this
meditating like I don't know almost like
wizard who comes down from the mountains
and
you know blesses you with I don't know
blessings but you can see his ability is
yeah that's the scaling one this is yeah
that's one of my favorites another one
is probably I I mean as far as I mean I
think Furia is just just the fact that
she can scale up so much yeah that she
can one shot a captain and win the game
there it's just such a tense moment when
you see her she's building up on the
back line right building building
building and then there's other units
that can actually increase accuracy in
fact there's one which is where's that
the um
what is their name why am I blanking
it's because we're on stream feet
twister
this actually might be my favorite unit
as well second favorite unit this one
another chill deck so it can do it has
two abilities it can if it can make a
friendly ability make their next attack
always hit no matter what or make their
enemy or an enemy make a mess so you can
I've seen games where Furia has been
like getting bigger bigger bigger and
then you bring out the Fate twister and
bless her with that and you're like
you've been trying to keep your guys
behind cover make sure they can't die
and then pull you out from behind cover
bless him move out you know you know if
you're one like 20 shot damage it's
pretty Epic though I do like this one
nickel this one oh not these that one's
good but um
where this there's another one like that
that uh where are you
the one that gives all your guys
movement
why can't I remember oh quite Sully
another chill like man so this one it
basically has an area of effect that it
can recharge basically five free
movements okay so if there's a unit any
of your units any unit if they if they
suddenly are moved
it does not yeah it just can't so this
thing is too crazy yeah so you it looks
like you're seeing a lot of support yeah
in the in the Chola yep
that's my favorite more questions
yes
um I'm not going to say this name what
language was this built in
uh programming language uh c-sharp
mostly and then some go I think for the
back end and I'm I didn't program on
this project not since the Prototype but
I don't know if there's other languages
in there I think that's all we have
right now
and this one I wrote it in English yeah
I was gonna say yeah yeah and it's all
Microsoft Word it's all Unity by the way
if anyone any programmers I did see some
questions in the chat about that okay
yeah and this question is for me uh what
has been your favorite part for this
game and you know the subnautica series
that's been your favorite part of the
creation process is it the actual
programming is it ideation what gets you
most excited I mean just making units is
just endlessly exciting because I just I
get to think about
you know what abilities could be like
fun to watch on stream or really
exciting or could allow you to use them
in really like creative or unknown new
ways like coming up with like something
something really simple that can really
have a lot of permutations one is just
so basic but like uh crankbait
is
so simple all she does is she's got this
hand
and she just throws the hand and she
it's a grappling hook it's like Scorpion
or like anything roadhog from OverWatch
but this thing you can do so many crazy
moves with this
and she's fast so she can move a lot
faster than most units so she can get
behind someone pull them out of battle
she can save people she can use it on
extelior she can get in front of him
pull him towards her and then he gets
his move right and just so many crazy
things you can pull people into minds
and then they blow up and yeah
so that's probably my favorite thing
it's just making
unit abilities and I could have answered
that knowing you yeah it's kind of
obvious when you get on a on a call
you'd be like oh I've made physical
units yeah check this out yeah yeah of
course now we have to go into pain mode
because we're gonna have to make sure
this is all Ultra balanced yeah but yeah
you know so far so good all your cool
units will get we'll get uh we'll get
nerfed no they won't they won't let's
get more expensive yeah exactly exactly
this is a fun one too
she she crits you know it's that don't
move okay which of course you can make
them not move yes something yeah
Mike W says and this is a question you
guys talked about earlier but we
probably have a different audience at
this point uh what's going to be the
cost to initially buy yeah it's 25 for
the game we also have a Founders pack
which is 30 30 which gives you like a
cool Astra skin which I think I should
show you here is it oh it's actually not
here you can only get it through the
founders pack
um but we do want to make you know make
extra models and uh VFX and sounds and
all you know sayings and emotes all that
stuff for the captains especially
um so yeah that's the founders pack and
then everything else we do have
currencies for getting boosters and all
these things but we've done with three
units in them yep yep randomized they
dust exactly yeah exactly and then you
can you can just buy the units that you
want exactly it's really easy to get all
the units you want we only have like 42
units right now it's it's pretty easy
just to get everything so if you buy the
base game and you play at all you will
have all the units very quickly we're
not trying to make this like 300 of a
quarter like you know some other ccgs
this it's not interesting to us um I saw
a thing for uh like how often can you do
a cargo run ah yes so that is one thing
where we yeah we're not totally sure
that you know we've had some people say
we don't they don't like this but we do
have cargo run tickets yeah so you need
a cargo run I guess contract you need a
contract to play uh if you buy the game
you get 15 contracts and then every day
you get another one I think that's I
think we ended up with one per day
the idea is we want you to be able to
win bonuses from from cargo run so you
actually win in-game currency by playing
the farther you get
also we've seen other games like
Hearthstone yeah uh they basically their
car their dungeon run was so good that
it basically like dried up their
multiplayer pool so they it was just
it's the kind of thing that it's so
addictive with all the upgrades and it's
like the slave Aspire feeling it's so
good that you basically stop playing
multiplayer and then no one can play
multiplayer so we want to make sure that
we have controls on that so people don't
just like binge like crazy so that so a
uh so you don't binge and so we keep the
multiplayer B so we give rewards and C
uh there's one other one which is
oh so you don't uh burn out
because that's the other thing you when
we had this mode originally you would
just sit there I mean I just played I
literally would play eight hours
straight until I fell asleep like it's
it's kind of like overly addictive and
then you burn out on the game completely
so we want to make sure we have some
kind of control there we may adjust how
how often that's redeemed or maybe make
them cheaper I mean they're free
basically I mean you can also spend
currency to get more but we just want to
have some control in there so we don't
have the game we want to make sure the
multiplayer continues
so that's how that works uh they also
wanted to know a post-purchase cost yep
um like add-ons or basically what kind
of money they're gonna have to dump
after that initial yeah that's a good
question we did just release an FAQ on
all the store stuff I don't actually
know where that's posted I think it's on
the crafted website but if you just I
don't know look on one of our socials I
think we've posted it recently I think
it went up yesterday
um so it has a lot of details but
basically we just want to make sure that
um you know people if they're going to
play the game a lot for years they need
to have put some money into it or play
the game so pay or play if you don't
play if you don't play then you need to
pay to get everything but if you if you
play then you don't need to pay for
anything except some of the high-end
Cosmetics like Captain skins and things
like that but we want to make sure that
the gameplay is always available to
everyone very easily so it's we're not
even going like the League of Legends
approach where they keep the you know
the heroes behind a paywall we're not
even doing that so um you can grind
everything for fairly easily but you
just got to play the game
and speaking of which I did want to show
we do have this uh this season track
which is just a free thing where
basically the more you play the more
extra stuff you get I didn't actually
show you the decals we have a whole
bunch of stuff in here we have the
banner shapes which I'll show you in a
second
um paint colors and including the metal
and stuff we have new paint schemes for
units that you can play that you can get
oh that's cool yeah he's like there's a
lot of cool stuff in here just we want
to reward people for being you know if
they like the game they should get cool
stuff
so that's all free I get boosters here
I wanted to show you that Banner stuff
because it's pretty neat
if I do new roster if I do yeah here's a
randomized banner if I can just hit this
randomized thing so you can basically
customize your banner for your your
roster
so it's like you know you can just do it
yourself or you can just hit customize
and you can like get all these different
crests you can see we have all these
Mastery levels for the different units
so the more you play and the more you
win with a unit the higher their Mastery
level gets and then unlocks all this
extra cosmetic stuff has no gameplay
effect it's just pure cosmetic uh all
these different shapes you can get so
you can you know it's just just kind of
like a part of part and parcel for a
Miniatures game right yep really
customizing your roster and making it
feel like it's yours
so yeah
pretty cool and Noel Gosnell wants to
know the uh
what age is this game appropriate for I
believe that the ratings we've gotten so
far are 12 up 12 and up
um I not 100 sure on that but we're
keeping the dialogue quite clean uh some
of the themes I don't know I guess on
the Audio Drama themes I'm not sure how
those would be rated yeah yeah I think
they're it's all pretty kid you know at
least teenager friendly we're trying to
keep all the language out of it I mean
there is you know mention of death in
the audio dramas so
maybe they're not all appropriate for a
10 year old but if I had a 10 year old
I'd probably let them listen to it I
played Doom with my 10 year old so see I
I think it all depends on the child yeah
yeah if you're Brandon's kid you can
handle it
Bart Thomas uh wants to know and you
probably touched on this a little bit
already Brandon how did the idea of Soul
burner turn into Moon breaker how did
the change from an outline
how did the change from an outline to a
game work I'll talk uh just a little bit
about that though uh remember that Soul
burner was a setting I never had a story
for soul burner uh it was all this
concept for something that um like
basically if I hadn't built the cosmere
this is like I could have built
something like this uh a self-contained
what one of the things I love about uh
Firefly
um actually I let it it's something
shared by Firefly and the expanse
um and Cowboy Bebop
um which is that
um they worked very hard to make one
solar system our solar system I think in
all three cases
um be expansive and interesting
um rather than going the big massive
universe that you see in something like
Star Wars or Star Trek which both have
their advantages but not having FTL and
by making it
um you know
all take place in one solar system you
get get a few things uh you don't have
FTL is like an Escape right
um and that just makes narrative
so much easier in a lot of ways uh
because you don't have that option uh
beyond that the um it's very hard to do
um in a giant Universal 3D
um escape with FTL any sort of terrain
um like planets being close to each
other doesn't matter so much when you're
working in terms of light years but when
you're working in a single Solar System
Scope which ones are close to reach up
to each other becomes much more relevant
uh and that allows for certain uh
politics and interesting ways and
economics and trading uh and so when I
hit on this idea for this one sun with
50 moons
um that you know uh and it's got all
sorts of cool aspects to it right like
uh it only rains on one side of the moon
because they're all tidally locked uh
and stuff like that and
um you only get light on one side of the
moons because they're all tidally lost
you have a rainy side A Rainy dark side
and you have a bright side but it's
pointed toward this massive
um uh red giant
um of a star and this stuff all comes
out in the audio drops yeah but we drip
it out too so like the visuals and the
concepting and all the stuff is so cool
um but it did not fit in the cosmere at
all uh and so I had all of this but I
didn't I mean I only had 5 000 words of
it and I ended up turning in something
like a 50 000 Word document or more uh
for the World building
um but
uh really it was a matter of taking that
concept and expanding it uh after
talking to Charlie about some of the
tonal things he wanted and things like
that but there was no outline for a
story uh that's not what soul burner was
I'm just in my Bliss mode I'm did you
were you talking yeah I was talking okay
yeah yeah you you
I'm painting more beautiful units for
your collection yes
I like your uh like the music yeah yeah
it's supposed to be really relaxing so
it's like you make the UI Go away You're
just kind of like just kind of looking
at the files yeah just like relaxing
and just as I'm watching you do this
what are going to be like the uh
the painting options for people who want
to do this obviously doing this with the
mouse is possible but how else can
people do uh we do we have tablet
support with pressure sensitivity so
that works already I don't know if we
support every single tablet but I think
we just support it in like a pretty
Universal way so far
um that's it
yeah tablet and
and mouse show us a decal unfortunately
I don't really I've never seen these
here but I think I know we support them
I think I just have to
you know in our play test get them
through playing you get them through
playing I haven't played and said and we
keep resetting the track because we
haven't launched yet but now as soon as
we launch there's one yeah so level four
you get all these differently Isn't that
cool that's a cool it's actually really
awesome so are those only visual um
uh nope no okay now they actually they
paint they basically burnt it's
basically paint so once you've got it
down you can actually just repaint over
it they're not like separate entities
they're actually just going to the paint
job so um is there any talk of ever
adding like separate entities and stuff
you can glue on yes yeah yes I think
that would be very very cool we just
have to wait until we see if the game is
popular it's popular yeah exactly yeah
it is Method already there we are so
cool but you got to play to get this
stuff yep
um
just get it for free oh and we have
these auras so we have different ways
that you can equip basically you can
equip an aura with your roster uh-huh
and then depending on the level of
Rarity of your units inside that roster
they they are affected in in more ways
basically the this is a cinder glow and
they get more Cinder glow if the high
the more rare they are okay not gameplay
again just zero gameplay
yeah that's super cool yeah so it just
gives you uh you know we want to make
sure that there's I mean that's we're
building a Miniatures game yeah you need
to customize it expressing yourself
exactly your Miniatures are exactly
that's why you play a game like this yep
um so I like decal pack there we are
I've seen all these so pretty cool
and like I don't know maybe you want
like a rose pattern a flower pattern for
your banner or yeah beat up
bullet holes yeah we have we have these
little Banner crests for so many
different units and then of course
different paint jobs so we did Gloom
side actually Gloom side version yeah
it's yeah yep so Gloom side is the uh
side that points towards rain and
darkness yeah
um so I don't know how the there was
there was discussion of a Gloom side map
uh I will do that later feel like I
played on one once no um just broken
light okay yeah um but there's
discussion of how do you how do you make
sure it's not too dark right yeah
um but yeah
it's early access can't you tell
Greg really wants you to add uh ships
that you can paint oh that's so awesome
you want to do on stream or terrain
where you could paint the terrain oh so
all these were props that you could just
paint them
um like build your own Maps kind of
stuff build your own maps I mean it's
screaming for it yeah yeah but we can't
do it for a little while or I should say
yeah sometime
got our hands full at the moment that
goes into another question
um that I saw from the chat from Ranny
uh can players mod this game like create
our own minis or something no we've
talked about Kit bashing and stuff but
it's just premature but I do know you
know kit bashing is so important in the
Miniatures community so it'd be really
cool to support that later if we don't
support it bashing where you can chop
apart two minis instead and just glue
stuff all together yeah yeah it would be
so awesome that's kind of what you're
just talking about yeah we got other
stuff on there but so far no mods yeah
no
I mean mods are really hard if you want
to cross uh support cross-platform right
and we do actually already support
crosstalk yeah it's from from the
beginning it just it just makes it so
much harder because uh if it's if it's
got any multiplayer aspect at all
totally um you know like mods get super
hard with multiplayer and then cross
platform multiplayer yep it just
uh yeah totally
Greg Reynolds says is there or will
there be a tutorial to guide new
painters oh painters we do have a
painting video I'm not sure if this
build has it is this the updated one
yeah we do have it right here so we have
like a little we have some videos in
here to just give you all the basics on
how to play and how to paint so we do
have that here and then other than that
it's just practice Yep this this
explains every all the basics in like
three and a half minutes it's pretty
darn simple
but we've already seen during the play
test weekends we've already saw like
half the streams were just painting only
so there's going to be great minis
painters all over Twitch in just two
days it's gonna be everywhere we'll
choose the skin color and dry this gives
you the whole breakdown we can paint the
whole face like this
but there's an easier way
I'm surprised we actually let you look
at that dream again I thought we
actually removed that but oh it's single
player so I guess it's okay
uh I love that the barks are all all
going now oh there's so many good parts
they're so funny
this guy's no glove
I'm hoping I I want to hear zax's bark
sometime oh they're so good uh like yeah
I know you were talking about some
really fun barks for him yeah yeah he's
he turned out great
oh this is a great unit this is one of
the most powerful units we have right
now
so basically anyone that's nearby or the
nearest person he basically becomes
their body bodyguard and he reduces
accuracy both for himself and them I
mean accuracy when people are attacking
them okay so his goes down but also if
you're trying to hit his nearest person
so he might move up here and try to
protect rickety yeah
um he's a pain in the butt you basically
have to move him out of the way before
you can deal with the person he's that
he's protecting
uh let's see
Xylo says the factions and moon breaker
each have their distinct Styles but are
you able to field any of them in a team
are there plans for different models to
allow everyone to match styles on a team
yes I think what they're asking is
um yeah yeah like the Staple in
Miniatures games is that you have some
kind of faction limits yep we don't have
those currently we don't we really just
don't have them because we don't have
enough units yet are you planning to do
that I mean it depends yeah I think we
have to be careful we might uh
yeah like to kind of summarize some of
the discussions I know that yeah that
Charlie has had
um I built moonbreaker so that the
cultures were not factions necessarily
um meaning if you're um if you're
methador yeah your captain is methadori
yep
um like yes though they're they're space
Romans kind of yeah
um but their army contains people from
every culture right
um it's not like you'll it and I feel
like uh when I was building moonbricker
one of my one of my things I said uh was
that look
um there's lots of different ways to
build cultures
um I want to pick a distinct time in
Earth's history and kind of draw
inspiration intentionally from a group
of Earth cultures the reason for this
being is we do this kind of
unconsciously a lot
um and I wanted to kind of own our
influences rather than
um be uh accidental at it because if
you're being accidental at it that's one
step for being insensitive right
um but if you're being conscious about
it you're like this is this is where my
inspiration is coming and they are not
like the method we're not just space
Romans they have their own thing but
kind of the concept behind them started
there yeah
um and uh but in the real world
um there was a whole lot of even in uh
in the time range I was using to start
my inspiration which is about 500 BC to
about 500 A.D
um where I S where cultures were a lot
more multiple cultural our cities were a
lot more Multicultural than we think
that they were
um and I wanted to if you're playing
methadori you can have anybody
on your team even if it were a straight
up yeah yeah you may want to paint them
methadory colors instead right uh and
things like that because they're all a
methadory team led by a matadori captain
but one other thing you have to remember
is the captains themselves are not
they're they're built to all be
basically solo uh they're not
representing a government uh you may
have a methadory captain you might want
to have a team that uses methadory
discipline so you're going to paint them
all kind of using methadory colorings
and things like that regardless of which
uh culture they're from but you also
more likely are going to be like hey I
hired this crew right from from around
the the reaches and This Crew oh you
just kicked your bomb that's cool Isn't
that cool
um and so your crew each represents
their own individualism or you might be
like let's build them all together uh
but the idea is like you're not you know
you're a captain you are an into
dependent Captain uh going out here
collecting Cinder and going on
adventures that's who you are yeah you
get to decide for your crew what that
represents and what that means and you
should paint them appropriately yeah um
I don't think there's any intention ever
to be like you know this piece that is
uh that is the the cholec support piece
we will create a different version of it
that it was the methodori support piece
so they can all be methodory it has the
same Powers I don't think there's a plan
to do that no uh now the trick is of
course is that this it's a staple in
Miniatures games yes of some kind of
fact it is and maybe you'll go that way
yeah and we may end up by making a few
huglers yeah the generic one if you have
so many pieces you might be like this
Captain can only have this yep but or
you get bonuses if you have them all in
the same culture or but at least during
all of the early design that's never
been a thing the exactly we're thinking
about it uh very very much exactly um
and so yeah once you have 700 pieces it
maybe helps to be like all right exactly
some guidance and what you're building
you should pick from among you know this
200 instead yep and it might even happen
earlier but we'll see we gotta we just
have to do it the right way because we
the game is all about like uh incredible
like possibilities yeah so you don't
want to limit those possibilities if two
cultures like say cholec couldn't be
used no chillic unit can be used with
any methador unit yeah that would just
be really sad yeah you know so we don't
we have to be very and it would be out
of theme right you've got and it'll be
out of theme like if your Captain's
recruited yeah they could be from all
around the reaches yeah um so yeah yeah
but I do think it's an it's an
expectation that people have so I think
it's something we want to keep thinking
about yeah and I've heard about it a lot
so
all right we are uh we're out of time
Charlie oh yeah yeah okay uh so this
um this has been very fun uh I suspect
it won't be the only time you've seen a
moon breaker on my streams yeah uh it
was fun to actually sit and chat and not
have to sign uh two thousand Pages your
hand is thanking you because they're
sitting over there waiting for you oh my
god um looming yeah at me so uh Charlie
thanks for coming out you're welcome
flew out here just yeah yes super fun
hang out with us and yeah and do some
windbreaker it's funny after all these
years we've only hung out a couple times
in person in person
exactly there's Zoom call or whatever
yeah I mean this started right before
the pandemic for us and then yeah but
we're back to normal we're back to
normal I did one flight out uh to LA and
uh hung out
um and then came back and we started
into it and then the pandemic yeah so my
gosh we're finally at the the gate the
finally it's finally pushing two days
it's two days two days less than two
days yeah oh my gosh yeah and then
hopefully you guys can all play and
hopefully hopefully you guys really get
excited about that Audio Drama because
that's where you start to see Brandon's
work yeah his World building really
shine and Dan Dan Wells is yeah Dan
Wells wrote all the Audio Drama scripts
and they're just fantastic they're
really heartwarming and you learn about
the world you learn about the units and
captains and I'm just really can't wait
to see what people think about those
so thank you guys we'll be back when
yeah next live stream all right it's
probably not for a while right uh
probably not until November right this
is kind of our October we just moved it
up because okay breaker was coming out
uh last week if we want to do one in
November because that's yeah the Lost
metal release and that so we'll have to
we'll we'll figure it out uh I just have
a lot of pages still to sign yeah find
out if you care how many but anyway
we'll see you guys thanks everyone or so
see you online
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]